[Music]
hello and welcome to another wolfram
tech talk this is arben calzici i'm a
content developer and instructor with
the wolfram u team and today we have
daria perechna here to tell us about
cryptography and the wolfram language
daria
hello urban
hi how are you
hey good it's good to be a part of full
from technology conference again
yeah it's this time of the year
it just it came around very fast this
year i feel
yeah
but
well going to be on land this year again
so uh
and this year has been uh different for
me as well as a part of wolfram research
because i have tried
you know been a developer here for like
five years this year i have tried
another role of myself writing educator
com content
and has felt good and so yeah i'm happy
to be here
yeah it's really nice to be able to you
know put the knowledge that you have to
i don't know what feels like really good
use when you when you do educational
content versus doing other content and
if the the rewards are a lot more
immediate
it feels nice to just put that stuff out
there and see people learning from it
well this has been a lot of work when
you get an immediate reward is like a
summer school programs
like i have done this and though you do
a lecture and you see people especially
the summer camp kids like their might
just go bright and you feel rewarded but
writing a full course uh the course that
i'm writing is introduction to
cryptography
and it's basically
trying to explain not just the
photography you know the way it is used
in practice and modern security systems
but all the way to you know its history
basic ciphers classic ciphers and so on
and so forth
and
this has been a good experience because
you know as a developer
working with cryptography in practice
i'm just using it very
how do you say very low level like we're
talking bits
you know and uh bytes of memory
things and when you try to explain it to
other people you want things beam or
visual more
you know more readable
yeah it doesn't uh it doesn't do much
good to people who are trying to you
know just learn or even just get an
elevator pitch to start talking at the
bit level so it's really nice to be able
to show things in this visual way that
you have in this notebook that we're
going to be talking about today
yes uh i was actually going to share it
now
uh this thing because in wolfram
you can do cryptography best and a bit
level they will give you security and
then you can write about cryptography on
example level and like i'm amazed you
know i have been a part of developing
this but i'm still amazed
a little self-congratulatory but we'll
take it
what
i mean
it's been five years
yeah five years of work
i guess you get some results after five
years of work eh
yeah well let me share then
so i i was going to share and
a snippet from my course oops
so this is one of the examples that's
talking about stream ciphers and stream
ciphers are those that encrypt a video
frame by frame basically as it goes
like in online streams also in like
internet voice calls
and we have an example data that's uh
you know this video of a little bird is
just
bird
you know i don't know why would someone
need to encrypt this
but
let's try
maybe there's already hidden information
in this bert video that people don't
want getting out
maybe
so in wolfram if you just want to secure
your file
you know you just go encrypt file
on it
and
you encrypt file and it's going to just
you know save it
securely no one is ever
ever going to
look at it
it's going to be bits ones and xeros
the password that i'm using here
password is not
exactly secure
but not quite no you know
is enough
for our purpose right now and this is
what it's going to look like on your
computer you know this is not very
exciting to put
you know an example
so wolfram allowed me to get you know
creative here make examples they're not
present you know in other educational
things because you can actually evaluate
it you can go step by step
and
now i have defined here
a key to encryption i have defined my
own encryption function okay so that
that key is you go to the image that
you're going to encrypt here
and um
okay and here you're encrypting just
this frame and not the entire video like
in the last example right
yeah because uh in encrypt file just
text file encrypts it here if because
the example is about encryption frame by
frame so that's what i'm trying to do
here right i take the image
size
basically create the key to be the exact
same size so every byte has its
representative in a key and gets
encrypted
basically separately okay so the height
and width of the image and then all of
the rgb values of each pixel they get
their own random integer
uh from zero to 255.
yeah which is the eight bits
okay
yeah the maximum possible
and then if you encrypt a single frame
you know it looks great
um
quite encrypted yes it looks quite
encrypted yes like nobody's gonna
decrypt it and this password you know is
better than password
okay and that that logical operator
you're using um
is there a reason you would use that
versus another one or is this just for
kind of the you know sake of the example
here
i mean this is more to by keep it simple
so i'm just soaring with random value
and this is a valid cipher it has been
used uh
it has been used quite a lot during
world war ii basically you just get your
message as long as it is
in ladders or in beds and you have the
key as long as the message and you just
add
each letter or each bit
of the key
it has worked
the only issue here that if you're doing
something really big you need a really
big key and you have to start yeah
yeah which would make sense in this case
you know that's maybe why we're not
doing the video here
and quite well
oh my god
because i've explained it step by step
so first we do a frame
and then we say that we actually do this
the stream encrypt that is going to do a
video frame map
on every frame of this video
and it's going to take our initial key
and just shift it by a short you know
just by frame index again to keep it
simple okay because i could have put the
normal encrypt function that you have
here in wolfram
but that were overcomplicated and that
right right you know it would not be
obvious that
if not for this it would be still
encrypted you know right so here you're
keeping that kind of same spirit of what
you did before and then as you go
forward in the frame list here
um you have all those random numbers
from 0 to 255 and then all those random
numbers get shifted up 1
you know modulo 256 so they go back to 0
if they go over 255
so you you kind of keep the same bit
value for that key but you have a
different key for each frame but it's uh
you know
you know what the key is for each frame
there
yes and that's how also the
you know industrial stream ciphers work
they uh the key also evolves so they
have some initial key and then as the
video or or the stream goes the key
gets generated on the fly based on the
initial bytes and here again i'm keeping
it simple by just adding frame index
raw more complicated algorithms to do
that
they use like shift registers and
i think shift registers are the mostly
used
and so doing it frame by frame
you actually do get an encrypted video
that is a video that looks encrypted
and like
i think it's amazing that you can do
that it was all from
oh yeah that's uh
i could not tell that that was a bird
for example
so for the for the stream encryption
then
um
what i'm hearing is that
when you generate a key for general
encryption
the way that that key kind of interacts
with a given piece of information in
this case a frame here there are
different algorithms for that so you use
that bitwise operation
exclusive or but you could use something
else and then in addition to that if you
have multiple pieces of information that
you're trying to encrypt
the um
the way that the
oh i framed this
so you have you have a
you have different ways that the key can
interact with the data but then you can
also change the key according to some
function and here it's a pretty simple
function but it could be kind of any
arbitrary function that changes the key
yeah i mean the
thing about stream ciphers that some of
them are still proprietary algorithms
like the ones that you know are in a
decoder of your tv
right may not be necessarily known to us
but they usually do have uh yes a
specific algorithm that how the key gets
generated on the fly because if you're
encrypting a file like i did here with
encrypt file
it knows beforehand that this video is
like you know 150 megabyte
that's it right
if you're streaming
you cannot know that how long will the
stream go you know how much time it
would take when i would interrupt
and also you know in practice they take
care of possible losses of connection
and so on and so forth
so they need to have an algorithm that
is both in the sender and then the
receiver
to derive the key on the fly as long as
it needed
right okay that makes sense and you
mentioned that you know encrypt file and
that other notebook there that one
knows ahead of time the size so kind of
like other wolfram language functions
which are looking at the inputs before
deciding specifically
what algorithms to use on them this is
doing something similar so this checks
the the size of the file and says maybe
okay well it's not really feasible to go
here and you know do this sort of
algorithm so i'm going to use a
different sort of algorithm that works
better for this file
well no that is not the case i'm just
saying that it knows that the file size
beforehand because it's stored on your
system
and so it just reads the whole file and
encrypts the whole thing
right away and the algorithm it uses
is
one of the
top notch and probably one of the most
famous
symmetric algorithms
is iis
so basically this password inside gets
derived
into a symmetric key object for the
cipher and it's going to encrypt it with
the cipher okay so 256 bits that's a
slightly bigger you might say than the
8-bit key we looked at just before
well
that key was actually bigger because it
was eight bits for four pixels ah yes
so the image you know if the image is hd
that's that's large yeah yeah this is
actually enough yeah like this cypher
has become a standard in 2001
and 256 bits
are still like enough for everyday uses
of everyone to provide security because
brute forcing
you know this is all possible amount of
keys
yeah brute forcing that takes
something takes more than we have uh
yeah in a lifetime
like a fastest super computer is still
gonna take billions of years
to do that for now
so
and it's it's a good uh you know
it's still small enough that you can
store
billions of them on any devices we have
in the world
and it's still good enough
to provide enough security
for almost everyone right
yeah
so
i mean i could go on and go on but this
course is like 25 lessons
so i'm not sure you're gonna wish to
hear all of that right now yeah i guess
uh i guess if folks are interested um
they can look forward to this
cryptography mooc that will be out
do you have a time estimate
i'm not sure but the lectures are all
written and we're currently recording so
as soon as it gets reproduction
you know we're gonna roll out as soon as
it's ready
right and that's a that's going to cover
some of the
uh inception the history and then it's
going to go into more practical
applications
yeah so it first goes first three
lessons are just history
from you know one of the first famous
cybers
is attributed to caesar so it goes all
the way back there and then goes through
you know
some more mathematical ciphers of the
renaissance and then goes to the
first world war in second world war
there was
great push for cryptography if you
you know if you watch the imitation game
for example
that's also sort of mentioned the alan
turing
crypto analysis team
and to the modern cryptography and the
cipher that you know i just showed you
eis
and then tries to explain you know all
of the things how they actually work and
what they do and what are the reasons
and what are the
maybe underwater
you know stones that can
make your security lesser than you thank
you it is
you know when you
there were historical examples
of people they were said you have to use
a random number here but they didn't
and so they weren't actually ripping
anything yeah i suppose humans are
famously bad random number generators
and
depending on what you're using as your
generator on your computer it might not
be much better from this perspective
sure but you might even
like there were examples where people
inside a random number would just put a
constant number in their code
without even calling around the y so
yeah you know you know you need a random
number and you're like a random number
seven there we go you just yeah mash the
seven button in the code perfect yeah
exactly you know okay
so cryptography is about mass and the
mass of cryptographic algorithm may be
secure but you also have to use it
correctly
and i also try to cover some of that
okay so we're covering all of this and
you know we've got some tips and tricks
you know
for for actually using these things
correctly
yeah
okay
here's the algorithm now you know how to
implement it but please don't
yeah well we'll see what the success
rate on that is hopefully people listen
who will
all right well thank you so much for
your time daria and it was a pleasure to
learn some about cryptography from you
and i look forward to the upcoming
cryptography mooc
well thank you urban for having me here
and people who are listening stay tuned
for my talk and for the upcoming book
all right thanks so much have a good one
thank you you too
that was darya berechna a cryptography
developer with our blockchain group and
her well from you mooc will be available
sometime in the near future hopefully
soon and as you've heard it'll cover
everything from the history of
cryptography to its uses in the real
world and you know maybe some tips and
tricks to avoid some pitfalls stay tuned
for more tech talks where we'll be
covering everything from differential
equations moocs to covet variant
analysis to microsoft excel integration
with wolfram data types see you in the
next tech talk
[Music]
you